[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp la seule
émission qui allie cuisine alimentation
agriculture écologie est aussi un peu
politique et cette semaine nous recevons
franz olivier giesbert c'est vous qui
allez passer à la casserole et avec moi
pour vous cuisinez jean-pierre montanay
bonjour jean pierre bonjour brigitte
beaux jours fente olivier giesbert
bonjour bonjour franz olivier giesbert
vous êtes journaliste éditorialiste
biographe écrivains romanciers
présentateur de télévision on ne sait
pas très bien comment vous qualifiez
tellement votre parcours est riche alors
je dirais simplement que vous êtes un
grand journaliste français français
encore car vous êtes né aux états unis
dans un paradis fiscal
le delaware votre père était américain
aux origines allemandes autrichiennes et
écossaises mais heureusement vous êtes
normand par votre maman vous êtes donc
un mélange iconoclaste de plusieurs
cultures alors ça donne quoi dans
l'assiette est bien de l'italie des
vrais pasta à la sicilienne qui l'eût
cru jean-pierre exactement brigitte au
menu une recette culte de catania
revisité par le chef auto languis un
d-pad végétarienne aux aubergines et en
dessert un apple pie une tourte aux
pommes en français dans le dos ou des
plats elle et vegan compte pour du
beurre ce sont les grands oubliés des
cartes des restaurants
il aimerait plus de choix dans les
magnifiques dans les pieds dans le plat
c'est une petite révolution pour lutter
contre la maltraitance animale un
abattoir mobile qui se rend dans les
fermes reportage à suivre en saône et
loire allez on passe à table tout de
suite cuisine et confidences
et oui franz olivier giesbert ou plus
simplement fog il y a des jours dans une
mjc 11 qui conditionne le reste de la
vie au point même de décider du menu de
cette émission ce jour là brigitte est
un jour de 1956 57 peut-être vous avez 7
ans et vous découvrez dans le frigo
familial coupé en deux et rouler dans du
papier perdican alors qu'ils aient
perdican et bien le bébé chevreau de
votre chèvre adoré rosette ce petit bouc
trop mignon mais turbulent a été
condamné à mort pour ses bêtises et à la
demande de votre père un boucher est
venu le décapiter d'un coup de serpe
drame épouvantable qui laissera le petit
fog inconsolable et en colère contre ces
hommes qui tuent des animaux pour les
manger adieu veaux vaches et cochons
dans l'assiette de l'ado rebelle qui
préfèrent les haricots et les épinards
aux nuggets le journaliste essayiste que
vous êtes devenu publiera entre deux
bios sur mitterrand et chirac un essai
sur la cause animale et 66 ans plus tard
il n'a pas changé et nous invite donc à
déguster des pâtes végétarienne aux
aubergines au lieu de riches bolognaise
à la viande alors fog vegan forever
végétarien végétalien parce que bon libé
gamme sont des cousins mais sont pas
retrouvés à diviser voilà c'est ça moi
je c'est vrai je reconnais que je mange
des oeufs j'adore les uns c'est le côté
prédateur de l'humain quoi on a on vole
et de la nature au volant n'a volé et
puis je dois dire que j'ai du mal à
cracher sur les freinages j'adore les
fromages mais j'en prends pas beaucoup
pour ma ligne plutôt plus que plus que
pour ils ont fait peu de les principes
moraux je comprends très bien les gens
qui se gavent de fromage puis c'est vrai
que ddd comment dire des repas de
fromage de vin rouge je pense que c'est
difficile de trouver mieux j'en tiens
disait perdican est mort ça veut dire
qu'on ne badine pas avec l'amour des
bêtes chez vous oui absolument c'est à
dire que je suis s'est élevé à la ferme
et donc à force de voir des tueries
notamment le dimanche mais aussi en
semaine des cochons des veaux etc je
voyais où j'entendais sur tout
c'est vrai que ça m'a dégoûté de la
viande assez vite c'est à dire vous êtes
à 14 15 16 ans je pense qu'un mais
c'était couche par couche c'est à dire
je commençais par un j'ai pu manger de
chèvres et de moutons c'est le cousin de
la chèvre après j'ai cessé de manger du
mot après j'ai cessé de manger delà du
bof pas de la vache et puis bon voila tu
peu à peu je me suis retrouvé une photo
où je vais presque plus de plus dur
quand je lis vos nous est encore un
petit peu de frais du poulet notamment
parce qu'à cause des enfants voilà je
cède toujours vous voir si c'est
vraiment du poulet fermier qu'on vous
vende le poulet fermier quand on a été
élevé elle va faire justement on connaît
ça alors entre 1500 connaît tout de
suite quand c'est pas un vrai poulets
fermiers et en général le boucher il
m'entendait après dans votre vieille a
écrit végétarien à géométrie variable ça
veut dire que on peut faire des écarts
quand même de temps en temps oui je le
reconnais par exemple en principe je
voudrais pas mangé de poisson je
mangeais beaucoup de poissons de ma vie
je continue à manger pour quelque chose
de très simple c'est la désocialisation
j'ai vécu mal me disant moi ma jeunesse
et mon enfance de végétariens puisque
très vite la pana repas vous disiez ben
je prends pas de alors c'est vrai il y
avait un chirac avait repéré ça chez moi
donc tout de suite il mettait toujours à
sa droite les gens disaient ouais
malavoy sa gauche il ya d'or giesbert
pas du tout ils voulaient prendre ma
viande scellés et temps en temps à me
demander il demandait des légumes comme
sur des légumes à bastos mais la plupart
du temps ça se passe et comment dire
c'était pas mon procès mais tout le
repas se faisait autour de ça mais
comment tu fais tu dois être malin tu
manques de faire et c'est
là vous nous emmenez en italie pourquoi
l'italie bon ben moi j'aime l'italie
puisque impossible de ne pas aimer
l'italie quand on est français bon un
personnage je suis vieux cons qui cite
qui dit dans un livre l'italie c'est la
france en mieux mon père avait dit
quelque chose semblable d'ailleurs ils
adorent et la france mais c'est vrai
qu'il avait une grande passion politique
et c'est vrai que la cuisine italienne
c'est complètement dingue on mange bien
france a tenu à en parler évidemment on
mange très bien en france mais vous avez
dans un truc couy un petit village
vraiment petit rien voilà avec la
zone était là pour entrer là-dedans
salle tout est sale vous asseyez
toujours oui enfin non je parle d'eux
c'est un exemple que c'est pas comme ça
l'italie mes pensées ses salles mais
j'ai des souvenirs comme ça
effectivement dans un resto rues sales
brusquement le plat arrive et c'est que
du bonheur parce que c'est ça aussi
l'italie à la sicilienne il ya quelque
chose dans la cuisine sicilienne qui est
différente encore oui bien sûr ben et
puis et pierre
le web a le numéro de vol a par exemple
pour ne pas le dire là on a dans
l'effort d'ailleurs qui est très très
très fort il ya pas de grillage à vous
pouvez goûter g20 de
toronto lundi vraiment il a revisité
justement à partir de l'italie il a
revisité ses pains italien c'est bon non
non c'est un israëlien
wafaq est très copain que tous les
palestiniens de la terre qui est
crédible alors pour effectivement cette
recette c'est vous qui nous l'avait
donné on l'a transmis par soit mais
c'est une recette d'auto lundi qui a en
fait revisiter ce qu'on appelle des
pâtes à la normale
sur les patins comme les pâtes
informations des pâtes italiennes chez
parce qu'il a rajouter un peu de piment
peut-être un peu de rigaud c'est une
recette originaire de sicile de la ville
de catane et vous savez cette ville
noire située au pied de l'etna et cette
recette mêle tous les trésors de l'île
tomates aubergines ricotta salle est
normalement là je vois que chez
françoise nos amis de du parmesan parce
que la ricotta salée c'est assez dur à
trouver on trouve très facilement la
ricotta frêche en france mais ça l'est
c'est plus compliqué à trouver on rappe
impôts de ricotta elle est revisitée
désolé parce que après wendel s'est
plaint des pistes où il ya plus d pilar
normal il n'y a pas autant de oui il ya
plus d pillay a beaucoup des landes et
là c'est très relevé la légende urbaine
dit que cette recette les pâtes à la
normale n'est le jour même où dans la
ville de catane été jouée au théâtre la
première de la norma de bellini on était
le 26 décembre 1831 donc ça fait un
moment qu'on déguste des os des pattes à
la normale pour bien réussir ses passes
ta je m'adresse à à franck il faut des
tomates de qualité comme les death and
may tarnos à cette saison préférée des
tomates en boîte elles sont meilleures
que des boîtes que des tomates pas
cuites certes c'est pas écolo voilà pour
les aubergines privilégier les violettes
coupez les en dés ou rondelle ça dépend
des des villes en sicile et les
aubergines rejoint là mais non
franchement les blanches aux six autres
oui mais les femmes mais dans cette
recette il faut les faire frire à et
enfin la ricotta donc pas celle fraîche
mais la salle à thalassa les plus
difficiles à trouver et on l'a rappelé
au dernier moment sur ses pattes et on
se regarde c'est bon oeil ce formidable
bon ben moi je suis un fan absolu
d'autonomie à changer la vie de plein de
gens et puis surtout ce qui est fabuleux
c'est
c'est comme chez des choses presque de
religieux le nombre d'enfants qui l'a
fait partout c'est à dire vous allez
dans des petits restos n'importe où
c'est un peu partout en france partout
dans le monde c'est une façon de
revisiter les cuisines avec c'est vrai
que ça touche particulière c'est les
épices et les légumes
vous aimez cuisiner vous
j'adore cuisiner depuis j'ai depuis tout
gosse en fait d'ailleurs ma grand mère
américaine prétendait toujours que je
finirais cuistot sur le france parce
qu'elle est la meilleure cuisine qui
soit gg mon fils aîné qui use in et
italiens allait alléger mon mon deuxième
fils un autre fils qui a une qui a une
qui est qu'avec un petit groupe la de
copains ils ont monté gagnant ses deux
restos italiens d'arauco mais je vis on
vit dans la vie dans la rue souvent dans
les restaurants de vos fils ben oui mais
on est dans la en vidant la gastronomie
nalla fall et chaleureux où l'on parle
on parle oui
mais le voulait on en prend plein la
gueule non mais je je je
je m'étais peut-être êtes là vous là
vous la faites régulièrement chez vous
moi je cuisine beaucoup mais cette
recette là c'est pas fan d'accord ça
comptait le sas et elle sait que j'ai
quelques plats comme ça et quelle
famille nous pensons bien calme quoi
s'ajoutent je ne sais pas alors via le
plaquer au suc est un peu plus tard
nature à vous à moi on sait très sympa
je fais tout j'adore les pâtes et je
fais des papes par exemple tomates
fraîches franchement qui sont pas
mauvaises
avec beaucoup de choses mais pas sur
tout ce qui est important on sait ça
quand on s'intéresse à la cuisine ce qui
est très important évidemment c'est le
produit est là la recherche que la bonne
tomates c'est un vrai boulot c'est un
plein temps
ce que c'est plus facile à marseille qui
apparaît puisqu'on a oui vous avez les
intéressantes or il faut un an que fog
il vit pas mal de temps à marseille si
vous savez pourquoi c'est plus facile
parce que le gros problème de la tomate
c'est que la grande majorité du fait de
leur non c'est de l'or peut être de 90 %
95 où il ya des chiffres varient mais
des tomates françaises sont produits
hors sol c'est beaucoup plus facile y'a
pas de bestioles à la tomate et fragile
elle attire des tas de saloperies et
donc on l'élève hors sol comme ça on a
des belles tomates que vous achetez des
tomates bio magnifique qui n'ont pas de
goût c'est ça et parce que les tomates
des sept voiles latines et c'est ce
qu'il appellera tomates de pleine terre
il y en a peu ses 5 % c'est bien
celle-là c'est vrai qu'on les trouve
facilement dans le sud c'est pour ça que
j'avais quand même on la trouve pas tout
l'est à oui mais vous la retrouvez
franchement aujourd'hui avec le
l'inventivité des maraîchers absolument
nécessaire mais ce que le show fait
tomber les gants d'écolo vous avez par
exemple dès aujourd'hui le melon la
saison commence en juillet et se termine
presque en avant fin novembre
c'était impensable il ya 50 ans et la
même chose avec les tomates les tomates
nos jours beaucoup de temps aujourd'hui
des tomates des bonnes tomates on n'en
trouve pas encore des vrais tomates pas
échangé
dans le vaucluse c'est incroyable si le
rire le paradis des tomates avec les
meilleurs tomates pour l'instant ce sont
les tomates sicilienne justement qu'on
peut très bonne je reconnais très très
bon être vous aimez aller faire votre
marché
et que du bio des circuits courts vous
comment vous consommez oui beaucoup de
circuits courts c'est sûr que c'est
extraordinaire surtout quand vous vivez
dans le sud est et vous allez aussi les
petits producteurs oui bah oui tout
simple
il ya tous ces producteurs qui vendent
sur la route très souvent ce sont des
gens qui ont des difficultés qui sont
cassé la gueule co2 reconverti lors lors
leur boutique on truque simili bio
agriculture raisonnée ou même carrément
bio c'est formidable mais c'est
formidable épouse mais vous avez les
meilleurs les meilleurs fruits et
légumes qu'on puisse imaginer bien sûr
mais c'est comme ça il faut être et puis
et puis vous avez tous ces petits
magasins il y en a de plus en plus à
paris
bobo les miens oui bon mais oui je
sentais qu'ils sont là des légumes ex
avec des vraies valeurs les rues du
lille s'est produit ce qu'on mange la
bafin s'était voilà c'est bon il faut
[__] pour
choisir ses légumes je pense qu'il faut
travailler un petit peu quand même c'est
à dire pour faut essayer l'échangé il
faut parler mais on arrive à se dorer
bien simplement effectivement reprendre
le le cabba et puis faire quelques
parfois est ce que vous dites et quand
vous êtes à marc sevely j'ai de la
chance d'être à marseille qu'on voyait
ses marchés qui sont plus coloré plus
vivant un peu déjà un peu un peu d'aidé
roland d'afrique du nord accès bien que
sans fil à oui biensur bébé sur gildas
chose mais moi je suis fascinée aussi
par les marchés du vaucluse bah c'est à
dire là où c'est vraiment pratiquement
du producteur au consommateur j'avais
les grands marchés de fin le célèbre
marché de velleron coustellet enfin tous
ces marchés qui où le producteur va
vendre cesser ses fruits et légumes et
vous avez là mais ça c'est vrai que j'ai
tendance à stocker c'est à dire d'autre
part avec d'énormes truc de tomates
c'est pareil j'adore le marché tout le
monde il ya ce petit marché bio et
agriculteurs tout en haut du cours
lafayette mais c'est que du bien c'est
ce marché que chantait si bien gilbert
bécaud les marchés de provence alors on
avait l'air de bien vous y connaître on
va voir si vous êtes vraiment incollable
c'est le quiz
alors comme l'a dit brigitte votre père
est américain il est né à chicago dont
l'une des spécialités culinaires et le
fameux je sais pas si c'est le mot
chicago style hot dogs j'imagine que
vous l'avez déjà testé sauriez vous nous
dire fog quels ingrédients ne figure pas
dans la recette originelle à saucisse de
francfort pur boeuf b purée de
concombres aigre-douce c'est ketchup des
pas aux graines de pavot quel est le les
ingrédients on peut le voir sur l'écran
qui ne figurent pas dans cette recette
culte de chicago le pain aux graines de
pavot non c'est le ketchup il n'y a pas
de clash heures en tout cas en milieu de
la moutarde jaune ouais voilà faut les
refaire vos classes à chicago
on a mangé attendait comment vous posez
des questions comme ça un pg t'as rien
gb je pars en courant
manger mais pas vincent jamais j'ai
mangé ce truc là pour moi alors vous
avez déguster ses pattes aux aubergines
lesquels de ses recettes italiennes
culte de pasta ne sont pas végétarienne
alors à pasta alla matri china des pasta
alla puta nhk c'est pascal nero 10 et
pia et des pasta alla compeed année zéro
retiré l'action italienne brigitte quand
même à formule alors
perdu largement perdu je donne ma lancée
à la main très concentré
disposition des trucs pour des potes
pour des professionnels de
votre fils il a toute ses ressources
à la métrite chanal tout année ce cas eh
bien il n'y a pas de viande dans la peau
tannée ce cas puisque ce sont des
anchois et un érudit sépia puisque c'est
à l'encré de seiche avec des tailles
with en revanche il ya de la joue de
porc dans la gouache y aller dans la lah
nitrates y en a hélas aussi dans alcon
binda neige voilà on sait très bien de
répondre aux questions
dans quelles traditions culinaires vous
avez été élevé vous qui est être né sur
le sol américain vous qui avez été élevé
aussi en normandie votre maman normande
aubin il y avait eu plusieurs
transitions évidemment et c'est beaucoup
la maj été levée en normandie je suis né
aux états unis mais j'étais lui en
normandie et c'est vrai que je suis
resté très attaché la cuisine normande
ma passion pour les coquilles saint
jacques je pense que ça vient de ce à
quoi sans la crème bien entendu puisque
c'est la crème à roissy ras du tout pour
des raisons vega mais parce que je
trouve que ça gâche pas ce qu'il ya de
tendance quand même produit on met de la
crème de mètres de là comme partout
attendait c'est très bon la crème je
peux pas dire faut pas manger de la
crème mais la cuisine normande vous
savez c'est un plat normal avec plein de
critères de jugement mais il ya la tarte
aux pommes pour moi j'ai une espèce de
maladie qui le calvados où si tu as ton
pam avec un peu de calme a vraiment
parlé de ses récits bourbon on espère y
voilà si on reste sur le salé moi disons
que le
la façon aussi de traiter les légumes
les pommes de terre par exemple la purée
la bonne purée qu'on peut manger en
normandie c'est formidable c'est un truc
très simple mais c'est vrai que là ici
j'imagine dans cette émission vous parle
de choses très compliquées mais
franchement une purée de pommes de terre
vous n'êtes pas obligé de mettre plein
de bordeaux vous mettez 2 on était de
l'huile d'olive à temps d écouter les
gens du sud on était de l'huile d'olive
bah oui d'autant que normand je me
mets la crème c'est pour autre chose on
préfère la laisser d'olive le goût de
l'huile d'olive est formidable c'est
merveilleux don puisque et puis
marseille qui a pris le pas sur la norme
est un peu quelques petits trucs dedans
c'est bien sûr un homme et la purée mais
je suis un grand comment dire ah oui
j'adore la pure et voilà
mais ça c'est ça vient de la normandie
c'est des souvenirs de normandie comme
les comme les multis beaucoup là bas
comme les déconfitures aussi je suis la
reine des confiture d'abricots figurez
vous eh ben je me souviens est toujours
dans souviens encore j'arrive pas
retrouver ce goût des confitures de murs
de ma merde et confiture de mûres
sauvages quand on récupère les murs un
énorme truc elle faisait dépôt il
s'était sublimé c'était assez peu sucré
je sais pas comment vous dire le goût je
retrouve jamais j'essayais d'en faire
évidemment j'y rêve pas et puis on n'a
pas donné ça
alors en france vous savez le repas
occupent une large place est
particulièrement en politique en tout
cas c'est souvent autour d'un bon plat
que se font les vraies histoires alors
c'est la brève de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé de réfléchir un
français vga souvenirs politiques autour
d'un repas est-ce qu'on a un qui vous
est particulièrement revenu à l'esprit
les repas
parce que
j'aime beaucoup et 80
mitterrand mais les pas de calais mais
voilà c'était pas
comment dire
ce n'était pas aussi enfin sinon que de
regarder chirac manger pourquoi ces
rames qu'est ce qu'ils valaient witt
juste un croyant alors vous déjeuner
avec lui vous savez qu'elle avait pris
un petit déjeuner normale et que vers
10h30
un de ses collaborateurs étaient arrivés
avec des sandwichs chauds s'ils sont
encore légion mais des trucs comme ça
enrouler dans le ppdri
manger ça et après un déjeuner entrées
plats desserts et fromagers
c'était juste dares qui était fascinant
c'est qu'il leur en prenait toujours
mais où ça allait alors je prétendais
toujours qu'il avait plusieurs thénia
vraisemblable
c'est moi qui l'avais nourrir leur
famille j'étais costaud il n'était pas
non plus non ils te pas énorme il
n'avait pas de lait petit ventre enfin
pas grand chose quoi c'était et vous
suiviez derrière quand vous étiez à ses
côtés vous manger autant enfin parce que
quand on l'accompagné en campagne est
alors je dois dire que le côté
végétarien chez moi
la muse et il s'en servait justement
mettant à côté pour montrer ma viande
mais mais je me souviens que la première
rend compte qu'on avait eue ensemble
c'était un
côté de bort-les-orgues un petit
restaurant absolument incroyable lieu
des fromages inouïe et il m'avait vu
craquer quoi c'est à dire que moi c'est
vrai que je sais pas manger trop de
fromage mais j'adore les fromages et la
france 357 fromage d'après le général de
wayne comment gouverner un pays 357
formage et non pas 357 fromage en france
quand on compte bien il y en a entre
1000 et 2000 plutôt 2000 que neil ouais
c'est juste incroyable partout et
j'adore les fromages alors c'est vrai
qu'elle est fromage du sud le banon
notamment au fromage de chèvre
extrêmement compliqué à faire des sous
sous des feuilles de riz fins et de
châtaigniers tout ça le raphia et puis
la petite goutte de
d'alcool d'autres vies pour le faire
exploser qu'on a pu régler complètement
et c'est vraiment que du bonheur mais
l'auvergne aussi là on était haut le
limousin c'est une terre le fromage
dingue et je me souviens mais j'avais
mangé sais pas combien comme j'étais à
côté de lui et que là il m'a entraîné
mais parce qu'il faut goûter 4 un truc
puis plus ça coule plus et purulent en
plus ça sent évidemment meyers et puis
voilà et c'est vrai que je me souviens
qu'on avait beaucoup sympathisé vous
savez comme ça peut arriver parfois avec
eux les les gens qui aiment bien avoir
un petit coup dans le nez là qu'ils se
retrouvent qui se retrouve autour d'un
verre nous on s'était retrouvés autour
du fromage on est allé très loin trop
loin
dans le fromage c'est vrai que puis-je
avait bien résisté j'avais bien tenu et
pour moi c'était un c'était un souvenir
très fort parce que quand j'étais avec
lui chaque fois j'avais l'impression de
sortir des guerres gantois et tous les
points c'était
comme ça alors les plats végétariens
vous le savez se multiplient en france
même si seulement 2% de la population se
dit vegan c'est le dessous des plats
les végétariens reste minoritaire mais
de plus en plus de consommateurs ont
réduit leurs portions de viande ou de
produits d'origine animale pour se
tourner vers les céréales les
légumineuses les fruits et les légumes
pour autant au restaurant rares sont
encore les menus à proposer des choix
importants de plats végétariens un casse
tête au moment de choisir une table
alors hélène bonduelle et andré lafon
ont suivi julien végétariens et un de
ses amis plutôt amateurs de viande
regarder
ça des saint jacques poêlées bar de
ligne gigot d'agneau poulet baisse comme
julian végétariens et romain plutôt
amateurs de viande veulent déjeuner
ensemble c'est souvent le casse tête
pour trouver un restaurant dans lequel
les deux collègues peuvent se faire
plaisir bonjour vous avez quoi comme
comme options végétariennes ou végétales
souffler
jours
peut-être
key moi je peux manger le groupe de
légumes mais un je vais pas je vais
quand même le payer 20 balles 25 balles
et je vais pas vraiment me faire plaisir
parce que je vais manger des légumes des
légumes à la poêle que je peux faire à
la maison et puis je vais avoir faim
dans une des alternatives végétal très
limité sur les cartes et souvent très
peu varié ça résoudre la question du
choix on n'a pas besoin d'hésiter mais
c'est vrai que si on veut manger j'ai
été impolie midi on ça commence à faire
beaucoup beaucoup de la végétarienne
d'ailleurs cette restauratrice
traditionnels ne reconnaît elle ne
lisent pas vraiment sur le végétal
ouais
d'accord d'accord et
des plats végétariens à la formule en
fait si tout on n'est pas du tout
d'accord ok c'est une question de
demande de la demande et pas assez
les plats végétariens ne représente en
effet que 2% des commandes en
restauration mais depuis cinq ans le
marché augmente et les français sont de
plus en plus nombreux à vouloir réduire
leur consommation de viande ce n'est pas
le cas de romain ce midi flickr qui me
tente pas mal
viande charolaise 95 voilà la base
grecque pour julien ce sera un burger
végétariens ou falafel
pas mal
c'est typiquement pas quelque chose que
je peux manger tous les mini c'est un
peu gras allocs pour manger végétales et
équilibrée julien a créé un guide
gastronomique végétarien
aujourd'hui ils testent ce restaurant
très engagé dans l'écologie les produits
locaux et végétaux au menu un poireau
brûlé pistaches et pinard et citron vert
l'idée c'est de faire un plat vraiment
100% vegan mais pas pour autant non
gourmand objectent souvent ce qui manque
dans les dents les delpla vegan ça va
être là la gourmandise pense qu'il faut
un peu être un peu autodidacte sur le
sujet parce qu'il y en a pas beaucoup
dans les écoles on n'avait que l'on va
vous apprendre quand on passe un bep ou
un bac depuis on apprend les basiques
bourguignon boeufs u lankais des choses
comme ça et ce qui est normal c'est
notre éducation c'est notre passé mais
aujourd'hui il ya quand même des moyens
qui est différent réseaux sociaux
internet en fait ce qu'il faut c'est se
créer sa propre envie sa propre culture
c'est le poireaux vinaigrette de mamie
réinventer
travailler c'est magnifique un peu sucré
salé
extraordinaire on échangerait pas contre
un contrepoison contre un plat de viande
la séquence fait pire c'est le regrette
pas tonton burger
alors prendre ce livier giesbert vous
qui êtes végétarien est ce que vous
aussi comme julien vous avez parfois du
mal à trouver un restaurant qui vous
plaisent ou il ya plusieurs plats
végétariens où il ya du choix finalement
c'était l'enfer pour le végétarien à
30 40
aujourd'hui nos 50 ans il encore
ça pourrait sous tend c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui quand je le restaurant tu
peux l'embêter mais vous avez vraiment
le choix danton tous les
restaurants non mais là avec quoi du
quinoa des pois chiches autrefois
50 ans j'ai pas je me trouvais août un
fond de la france
voire portage ai je demandé est-ce que
je peux avoir juste des légumes ouais le
chef vous faisait la gueule et vous
disais mais non il n'y a pas d'enfant
pas belle la vie et toute façon à la fin
il arrivait avec une assiette avec une
grosse vente avec de la viande
il me terrorisait littéralement et donc
on est on est sorti de ça et c'est très
bien c'est un système beaucoup plus
libéral aujourd'hui où chacun choisit ce
qui est tout à fait normal moi ne savez
je suis pas non plus un jeu combat pas
la viande j'ai comme gta vers la ferme
je sais que les paysans les éleveurs ils
vivent de ça et franchement il y avait
beaucoup je respecte parce que j'ai bien
vu le bien-être animal pour beaucoup de
ces éleveurs frange pas mesquins jusqu'à
demain comme si un choix de plats
diversifier dans la cuisine
traditionnelle française pas tellement
quand on regarde bon gros vous la
traditionnelle sont généralement à base
de viande comme on peut se plaindre mais
franchement ça fait des progrès sont
considérables d'ailleurs là qu'est ce
qu'on est en train de manger du loto
bingo est-ce qu'on s'y trompe pas
souvent vers des pâtes on peut faire des
pizzas vers la cuisine italienne
justement ouvert les les quinoa l'ailé
boulgour les légumineuses vous avez vous
avez raison mais c'est aussi c'est très
bien aussi une façon de le faire à la
française enfin moi j'suis pas je n'ai
franchement j'ai pas envie de me
plaindre par rapport je dirais pas
l'enfer bouge bien mais franchement
c'était abominable est-ce que vous
appréciez un restaurant quand il ya dans
la carte et un petit carré ça se fait
maintenant dans certains restaurants
même autour de l'assemblée où la ses
marques et plats végétariens ou en piste
le flèche plutôt ccco pas pour des gens
comme vous ça vous apprécié ce geste
fait pas le restaurateur parce que sinon
il faut aller picorer deux entrées en
jeu
l'apprécient beaucoup mais ce qui est
vrai c'est que moi j'aime beaucoup
prendre deux entrées vous mettez des
poires ont tout de suite je deviens
dingue évidemment je prends toujours les
points où c'est évident ouh là où le
céleri rémoulade s'est passé des choses
comme ça moi je vois un repas formidable
avec entrée de poireaux et du céleri
rémoulade mais je suis le plus heureux
des hommes donc j'ai pas forcément
besoin d'un plat particulier on trouve
très bien non je trouve que par rapport
il ya 50 ans c'est le jour et la nuit
s'améliore tout le temps ça j'ai pas
tellement envie de me plaindre pouvoir
d'où l'on vient de toujours un peu
montré du doigt parce qu'aujourd'hui
cette critique par exemple n'apprécie
pas tellement là la cuisine végétarienne
on va se retrouver plutôt d aider des
restaurants traditionnels avec avec
souvent de la viande et du poisson en
france on épie que rien
mais c'est ça je ne comprends pas dans
votre question c'est comment moi j'ai
l'impression d'être assez downeast même
si j'essaie de me corriger souvent et/ou
épicurien si vous préférez et je crois
qu'on peut être végétarien et puis plus
rien moi je connais beaucoup de
végétariens épicurien ça vient ah oui on
aime les légumes regardez moi j'ai pas
j'ai mangé beaucoup plus qu à regarder
l'assiette est presque terminée parce
que c'est sensationnel mais c'est la
preuve par quatre c'est
franchement ça aurait été mieux très
bien s'en vient on sera enfin il est
formidable et est ce que vous mettez les
pieds dans des restaurants l'heure la
plus ravie connais un peu par l'éditeur
vegan alors uniquement vegan est ce que
ça vous intéresse vous allez voir est ce
que ce sera bien sûr est ce que vous
trouvez votre plaisir oui c'est moi moi
je c'est vrai que je suis plus tourné
vers le végétarisme c'est à dire j'aime
pas trop l'idée des deux sociétés voyez
l'idée d'avoir son petit resto à la
communautarisation de la dette moi je
suis pas très pour ça et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que je j'ai toujours accepté
de manger du poisson justement pour
éviter ce qu'on appelle qu'est-ce qui
était terrible il ya 50 ans où je vais
jetter la végétaline vous conduisez
forcément à la désocialisation
je me souviens avoir parlé avec des
copains végétariens comme moi et à quoi
tu mange du poisson bah oui ben sinon je
mange rien après on va faire tout tout
le repas autour de moi comment tu fais
pour quoi est-ce que tu étais malade ou
pas tu prends pas de faire un bon parce
que c'était c'était ses croyances quoi
aujourd'hui on découvre que voilà hop
est végétarien est en forme enfin c'est
pas l'impression qu aux etats unis ils
sont allés plus vite que non c'était le
temple de la malbouffe et aujourd'hui il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de restaurants vega
n'ont plus de choix disons dans les
cartes qui comme lui mais j'ai découvert
un peu quand j'ai travaillé là bas dans
les années 80 j'ai découvrir et
qu'effectivement il y avait énormément
de resto déjà végétarien de resto bio
enfin sept types de cuisine un peu
italienne avec dix ont revisité et ça
c'est vrai que ça c'est apparu ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui disons-le à la
mousse bobos qui partout en france à
paris mais dans toutes les grandes
métropoles elle était déjà très présent
je me souviens à washington dans les
années 80 il y avait beaucoup de restos
comme ça mais c'est très bien c'est une
bonne évolution alors on va dire c'est
une cuisine on ne sait pas vrai parce
que c'est une cuisine européenne
principalement avec un peu de
moyen-orient mais c'est une cuisine
européenne et c'est très bien ça vous
choquerait qu'à l'elysée y ait un plat
un chef d'état qui soit reçue avec un
plat sans viande
ah bah oui je serai bien ceux d'en bas
et je voudrais bien ça nous est arrivé
ce qui est arrivé est bien sûr
simplement ce qu'ils auraient fait que
le végétal en général quand il fait de
la politique la tendance à ne pas le
crier sur les doigts
la tendance a pas le crier sur les toits
il est oui il est prudent là dessus
parce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
perdre des voix comme vous mais si vous
dites c'est jeter l'opprobre sur sur une
profession une profession qui fait
souvent très bien son boulot
comptez pas sur moi pour taper sur les
paysans
des moutons noirs jeu on l'a 10 2% de
végétariens en france mais 37% de verser
550 ça monte bon effectivement mais les
chiffres sont toujours là 37 de saumon
sur l'ex-site à rien donc qui mangent
moins de viande souvent par respect
d'animal alors le bien-être animal est
il devenu une réalité on en parle et on
met les pieds dans le plat
ça va vous plaire un franz olivier
giesbert 1 qui avait mal digéré votre
visite d'un abattoir quand vous étiez
adolescent c'est une révolution pour les
éleveurs terminée l'insupportable
transport des vaches en camion vers
l'abattoir et vers la mort l'abattoir
mobile inspiré d'un concept suédois a
débarqué en saône-et-loire son principal
atout bien sûr une meilleure prise en
compte du bien-être animal c'est un
reportage de stéphanie des pierres et
d'alizés boissons ce camion sillonne la
bourgogne de ferme en ferme car c'est un
abattoir mobile une première en france
ce ne sont pas les vaches qui partent à
l'abattoir mai l'abattoir qui vient à
elle un concept leboeuf éthique créée
par emilie janin une éleveuse engagé
pour le bien-être animal c'est un
abattoir voilà mobile mais il doit
répondre à toutes les obligations comme
un abattoir classique donc effectivement
on a trois gros camions donc ici c'est
le camion qui nous sert de logistique ou
effectivement on m'a stocker les cuire
les barrières les bacs et là c'est
l'abattoir en tant que tel et puis à la
fin de la chaîne donc la carcasse elle
va être fendu en deux on va les
transférer dans le troisième camion qui
est ici le plus gros depuis deux jours
le convoi est installé sur une
exploitation au nord de mâcon ici jean
luc épaules élève 160 vaches limousines
ils font appel à l'abattoir mobile du
boeuf éthique pour la première fois donc
là on est devant la case des vaches qui
vont qui vont aller dans le camion du
boeuf éthiques donc c'est les vaches
combi shon et qu'on essaie d'engraisser
le mieux possible pour avoir une viande
de qualité ils sont déjà convaincus
normalement c'est des animaux qui sont
chargés dans un camion la nuit qui font
des kilomètres donc là il ya toute une
phase de stress là y'a rien elles sont
chez elles elles ont leur odeur elles
sortent par la porte comme si elle
allait au près sauf qu'elle montre dans
le camion et c'est fini
elles sont beaucoup moins stressé et
nous aussi ouais parce que parce que ça
nous fait quelque chose se dire elles
vont aller jusqu'en bretagne elles vont
rouler pendant
une nuit une journée et puis dans quel
état ils vont arriver quoi mais on le
voit pas en maîtrise plus là on maîtrise
tout jean-luc épaules dont une douzaine
de bêtes à abattre
chaque vache quitte les tables pour
rentrer dans le camion
elle est assommé
les techniciens vérifient que l'animal
est bien étourdis avant d'être saignés
puis la bête et découper tout se passe à
l'intérieur du semi remorque nous ne
pouvons pas filmer pour des raisons
sanitaires après six mois de rodage le
système est bien au point est très
différent d'un abattoir traditionnels on
n'a pas le rythme à respecter on a des
bêtes sont tranquilles sans stress et on
voit des éleveurs ont fait la fête
à l'abattoir traditionnels
une quarantaine d'éleveurs font déjà
confiance à emilie et à son équipe c'est
l'aboutissement de cinq longues années
de travail et de démarches
administratives pour importer en france
cette innovation suédoise pour mettre en
place la batmobile on a monté tout un
modèle économique où en fait on propose
une service clé en main aux éleveurs
sert qu'on achète la viande on achète
les animaux vivants on s'occupe de les
abattre et on vend la viande sous la
marque leboeuf éthique et donc en fait
on entre avec des professionnels
restaurateur débouchés des particuliers
ce qu'on travaille aussi avec des
collectivités locales notamment pour
permettre l'approvisionnement local en
viande sur les cantines l'enjeu
désormais c'est de trouver plus de
débouchés pour cette viande produite en
circuit court franz olivier giesbert
abattoirs ambulants le végétarien que
vous êtes retient le mot ambulant où le
mot abattoirs ah bon évidemment parce
que je sens que ça change quelque chose
un matin je suis pas contre les
abattoirs et contre les bouchers et
façon c c'est un univers qu'il faut
accepter et j'ai même des amis bush et
que j'ai vu travailler et qui aiment
leurs bêtes ça c'est tout à fait
possible dans le voilà dans seront bien
sûr donc donc vous faut arrêter ça je
sais pas c'est pas je ne suis pas dans
notre corps j'ai pas jamais entamé une
guerre de religion est un talibé c'est
vrai ce phénomème delà de l'abattage
comme ça qu'ils se déplacent l'abattage
ambulants ses anciens déjà ya à peu près
une trentaine quarantaine d'années ou
quand aussi revoir ça beaucoup en
autriche devrait annoncer doit éviter
mais effectivement on vous l'avait déjà
on est arrivé un peu tard en france
comme souvent oui c'est bien d'arriver
sa virilité bombay mais c'est formidable
c'est formidable parce qu'effectivement
c'est quoi la vie d'un animal en france
dont beaucoup
enfin pas partout parce que je suis bon
je le répète il ya des endroits où ça
marche pas comme ça mais vous avez
l'enfer de l'élevage l'élevage
industriel
et c'est vrai intensifs on a quelques
images en tête mais par exemple ces
pauvres vous comme ça mais c'est
monstrueux après après vous avez l'enfer
de transport les veaux qui font 1400
kilomètres pour aller crever en italie
avec avec vous savez sous toutes les
chaleurs vous regardez regardez sur les
zones comme ça donnerait dans l'est dans
les dents les autres ou de vous verrez
vous verrez que
il ya parfois qui sont morts qui sont
couchés comme s'il était mort donc c'est
juste moi et après l'enfer de l'abattage
en plus souvent pour couronner le tout
l'abattage rituel pour banca bête sous
trop bien c'est à dire qu'il essayait
avis voilà des travaux oui et donc elles
vivent entre l'abattage rituel a
évidemment eu tout tout tout temps de
l'abattage rituel que ce soit le halal
ou le cacher je suis content on pourrait
l'interdire a aujourd'hui enfin cela il
ya des pays qui là c'est marine le pen
qui proposera des pays tiers parce
qu'elle dit ça que je vais dire je suis
contre il ya des pays qui l'ont interdit
et je trouve ça très bien c'est évident
pourquoi parce que parce que la bête
sophie oui mais pour quoi faire souffrir
les bêtes pour au nom d'un principe
religieux absurde puisque il est avéré
que la bête quand on les tours 10 elle
peut se réveiller donc si on les tours
10 et pour qu'elle ne souffre pas et à
ce moment là on la seigne et donc
pourquoi pourquoi l'obligé à souffrir
pourquoi faudrait-il c'est pas écrit
dans le c'est pas écrit dans l'est dans
les textes sacrés ça c'est pas c'est
absurde donc faut faire il ya des pays
qui le permet et puis par exemple
quelque chose qui se fait en grande
bretagne qui est très bien c'est la
vidéo partout dans les abattoirs ça
l'avait premier manuellement oui eh ben
je pense qu on pensait que ça change je
pense oui bien sûr parce que des
pratiques changerait d'ailleurs ce
serait compliqué pour l'abattage rituel
parce qu'on fait
mais à l'abattoir on n'aime pas les
bêtes
c'est parce que je dirai pas ce que moi
j'ai visité des abattoirs et j'ai vu des
abattoirs par exemple densité je passais
une journée il ya longtemps pour faire
un roman policier qui se déroule à
l'abattoir de sisteron qu'est le premier
abattoir vins de france j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment d'excellentes conditions
c'était vraiment les bêtes étaient
cryptées le mieux possible à résidence
et un mauvais moment à passer je vais
pas dire qu'elles sont contentes c'est
sûr mais sont bien traités avec respect
l'excision de banques sont mal traités
que pensez vous de ces vidéos l214
puisqu'on parlait de vidéos qui filme
vraiment la rose humour qui sous là
heureusement bah oui ils sont drôles en
soi dallaire bien évidemment bien
évidemment si on tousse et très bien les
amateurs qui touré qui ont été fermées à
cause de maltraitance et d'ailleurs tous
ceux qui s'en plaignent et n'ont qu'à
accepter la vidéo puisque vidéo
apparemment c'est très compliqué il ya
des pays où ça ou ça se fait ou ça
marche et ça permet d'empêcher les ics
sais pas ce que tu en entends évidemment
les amateurs a pas se raconter
d'histoires temps en temps on rate une
bête bon on est là c'est cette atroce ça
peut arriver mais vous savez très bien
pourquoi pourquoi la massacrer avant la
tuerie parce que c'est ce qui se passe
souvent les coups de pied les trucs la
violence on voit ça sur des sur les
truies sur les cochons mais si c'est
juste un sens et donc donc et il ya deux
dans chaque abattoir il ya des moutons
noirs des gens qui se comportent très
mal mais j'ai vu de mes yeux vu des gens
qui se comportent très bien avec
efficacité qui ont sont conscients du
travail qu'ils font alors j'ai cité
sisteron je pourrais citer d'autres se
battra aussi parce que j'en ai vite
qu'elle que ça vous avez écrit deux
livres d'ailleurs sur la cause a
justement pour dénoncer ça justement
pour qu'on prenne davantage en compte
finalement la la la conscience de
l'animal bah je pense que on vit dans
une société vous savez où on avait
quatre principes comme ça de jolis
principe en fait l'animal on le connaît
pas et
apple faut dire le bobo urbain il sait
pas trop comment ça marche si c'est pas
ton et dire voyez quand vous vivez à la
campagne pas même le paysan le sait le
bon paysan le bon éleveur il y en a
plein le regard
on se parle avec ces animaux sont très
intelligents les veaux sont très joueurs
bon après évidemment la vache avec ses
gros sabots du malade se déplacer mais
mais il faut voir si c'est le cochon
l'intelligence du cochon est un animal
qui se reconnaît tout de suite dans la
glace là vous mettez un miroir ne sut
pas fils et qui sait juste qu'il fait
pas des grimaces pour voir ouais donc il
ya une vraie intelligence et quand on
vit à la faire on le sait donc pourquoi
maltraités tous ces animaux pourquoi
pourquoi mais au nom de quoi au nom de
quoi du profit enfin il faut tout revoir
à ce moment-là
à l'abattage classique on interdit
l'abattage non non on revient à
l'abattage classique qui était quand
même au
temps du général de gaulle c'était
brigitte bardot qui avait imposé sa
c'est à dire on va systématiquement
étourdir les animaux avant de l'essayer
il faut revenir à ça bien sûr et puis c
de faire les abattoirs les amateurs le
plus proche possible pour éviter des
transports qui sont très traumatisant
mais enfin combien de fois vous avez vu
des énormes d'énormes camions de cochon
train de crier dans les sens sans fin ou
où les bons ou les rats vous entendez
des cris atroces danse et d'autres
débats pardon mais non je vais pas vous
entendre vous devez regretter qu'elle a
une twingo soit plus dans la liste des
présidentielles parce que c'était au
coeur de son de son programme la
candidate animalistes qu'on a reçu ici
mais bon j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
lui et pour les animalistes mais toute
façon c'est un combat très long parce
raconter d'histoires ça sera pas réglé
la prochaine présidentielle woods doit
même dans 10 ans 20 ans on parlera
encore mais ça progresse et moi je suis
très optimiste de ce point de vue parce
que je trouve la cause animale depuis
par exemple j'écris mes bouquins je
trouve ça a énormément progressé ça
progresse et on voit qu'on va vers ça
c'est obligé c'est le respect on est
quand même dans une société on a fait
des progrès de ce point de vue n'ont
peut-être pas hélas insuffisant reste de
l'europe il se passe des choses atroces
en ce moment où objecte mai mais il y à
il ya quand même des progrès et je pense
que la cause animale c'est une bonne
cause et l avance quel regard vous
portez sur la chasse
je fais partie je suis assez mesuré là
dessus parce que je pense qu'il ya des
problèmes de régulation
j'avais je véhicule pendant une époque
dans là tout près de la forêt de
brotonne et je vois bien qu'ils avaient
des problèmes de régulation c'est quand
il ya trop de chevreuils sangliers
derrière oui je parle pas des sangliers
parce que j'ai toujours un faible pour
le sorbier je dois dire mais enfin pour
les chevreuils si maintenant ils ont une
façon de tuer des arbres qu'il faut à un
moment donné on appelle ça voilà ils
font des battues et d'en réguler on
régule un peu bon ce type de chasse que
ce que je déteste c'est la chasse voyez
dans l'
espace d'abjection élèves les belles
âmes or voilà quand on entend le
président de la fédération des chasseurs
dire que voilà willy schraen qui dit
c'est formidable c'est non non non non
non moi j'ai d'ailleurs j'ai vu des
chasses et assister à des chasses et
franchement j'ai jamais trouvé de j'ai
jamais de jouissance à dire oui c'est ce
que jusqu'à avait bien contient leurs
salaires
chez certains chasseurs vous avez la
jouissance pas tous et vous avez une
forme d'un mélange de jouissance de
canton a tiré l'animal éreintant des
froids quand on le voit et et de
mélancolie et de tristesse ça se voit
dans le regard ne faut pas l'oublier
dans un an - non je suis désolé je ne
jette pas l'opprobre sur tous les
éleveurs surtout les amateurs surtout
les bouchers on dit surtout les
chasseurs on a aussi besoin de notre
société on a besoin de chasseurs avant
l'idée d' éradiquer les sangliers ça
aussi pour arrêter avec ça ils ont le
droit de vivre aussi
peut-être pas point trop n'en faut
oui mais parfois ils exagèrent aussi
voilà il faut essayer de trouver un
système system in tout le monde peut
vivre en un mot corrida ou pas de
corrida parce que ça finirait sa fille
ni le chapitre bien être animal en
nouveaux prêts bah je vais choquer
encore mes amis de la cause animale
c'est que je trouve que c'est pas une
priorité je trouve que quand on aurait
réglé le problème des abattoirs c'était
là l'idée de mon amour l'idée non mais
l'idée de nom mais ce n'est pas pour ou
contre évidemment je suis content mais
mais dans l'absolu mais dans l'absolu
évidemment fait mais attendez mais c'est
pas une priorité la priorité enfin quand
on pense tous ces gens qui parlent que
de cirque de corrida alors que il se
passe des choses monstrueuses dans les
élevages dans les transports et damas
damas thouars je dirais c'est très
urgent et madame al madj ans elle est là
et il faut le faire avec les paysans
avec les bouchers qui souvent ne demande
que ça il faut parler avec les bouger
c'est incroyable a reçu l épreuve le
bourdonnec bennes ont même parlé de ça
c'est peut-être pas le plus comment dire
disert sur le sujet mais
vous y en a d'autres par exemple mon ami
hugo je trouve que là dessus hugo
desnoyer il est vraiment
très attaché à la cause animale je l' ai
vu faire je les ai vus en action c'est
vrai que c'est quelqu'un qui est très
attaché allez on passe un dessert à
présent c'est votre péché mignon
c'est le temps du sucre et mon cher
franz-olivier giesbert avec un apple pie
en bon français une tourte aux pommes un
dessert qui dit beaucoup de vous un le
mariage de la pomme de normandie terre
natale de votre mère et la culture us de
votre père si on doit rétablir une
vérité historique ce sont les colons
venus d'angleterre qui sont à l'origine
de cette recette dont la première trace
écrite date de 13 131 un bail à
l'origine l'apple payet un mélange de
morceaux de pommes de sucre de matières
grasses et des pistes comme la cannelle
dans une pâte qui est non sucré alors
question basique a préféré vous l' apple
pie ou la tarte aux pommes oh certes aux
pommes dans la tarte au pas mais mais
mais mais là je dois dire c'est toujours
le goût de madeleine de proust label
paille c'est ma grand mère qui faisait
des appels payet fait aussi d'assembler
associé aussi des blueberry paille ah
non parce que tout est écrit c'est ça
c'est une enquête et elle faisait des
appels paille ma grand mère américaine
que jet d'eau voilà avec la cannelle
comme vous dites toujours très attention
il faut faire attention aux fruits c'est
à dire que il ya une bonne tarte une
mauvaise stark la mauvaise start c'est
la tarte avec des mauvaises pommes et
les spams ce à quoi des gones pavois la
reine des reinettes ou des boskoop un
peu plus tard enfin vous avez plein de
l'espèce on sent la cour n'a pas marché
oui bien évidemment
les fait revenir je
vous ai pas besoin de bear the papas
intervenir maintenant vous vous sait
très bien le beurre j'ai rien contre le
beurre je répète mais le problème c'est
enfin c'est pas de mettre du beurre
partout c'est que la pâte avec la pomme
ça suffit c'est topissime que vous avez
pris la meilleure pomme qui soit
égouttez la pomme avant de faire votre
apple pie ou votre tarte aux pommes
fraîches avec vous la mangez comme sa
nature
alors bon côté normand parfois c'est
vrai que si vous
filer un petit verre de calva et qu'on
la flore n'a pas trop content mais
auquel le cidre beaucoup moins bien
house est très bon le sud mais c'est
vrai que ça fort mal alors question un
spécialiste les pommes on doit les
couper en dés comme c'est fait par chez
françoise ou plutôt en tranches qu'est
ce que vous préférez plutôt étrange bon
ça c'est très dur mais aussi hélas pas
briser ou savez vous préférez tarte au
brise et autorisait plutôt m'enfin
attend des sables et c'est bien aussi
non à la dessus je vraiment je suis très
ouvert on voit que soient interdites
bonne tactique des bonnes tartes ou
goûter à toutes sortes oui mais je la
goûter alors comme nous sommes en pleine
campagne présidentielle vous le savez
nous nous intéressons aussi aux us et
coutumes de l'elysée et aux habitudes
des présidents c'est le quiz
présidentielle
alors brigitte on connaît les caprices
de stars mais à l'elysée le cuisinier
doit aussi composer avec les caprices
des présidents alors quel président
franz olivier giesbert fait venir exprès
du maroc un maître autel d'hassan ii
pour initier son chef à la préparation
du thé à la menthe alors à pompidou b
valéry giscard d'estaing c'est chirac
des mitterrand voulu réchauffe non je
n'en sais me dérange pas et millions rs
mitterrand qui avait une lubie études à
venir un marocain à l'elysée pour
préparer le thé à la menthe alors on
vous a demandé aussi et quel était votre
film préféré et vous nous avez dit barry
lyndon ouais hein et kubrick parce que
c'est un film parfait c'était vous
prenez chaque plante un tableau c'est un
tableau de grand maître c'est incroyable
à chaque fois que je regarde ce film je
suis là complètement bail à la bande-son
hockey incroyable mais il ya surtout le
le travail qui fait sur chaque plan
c'est beau tout est beau c'est un film
absolument magnifique pour moi c'est on
peut pas fermer enfin le parrain numéro
un de mes premiers le premier pas c'est
pas mal non plus voit aussi mais je me
paie l'histoire jeunes intrigant
irlandais ça ça vous année l'histoire
les bonnes sera classé littérature
britannique mais c'est pas tellement ça
c'est baby toute façon les acteurs sont
excellents tout est bien mais c'est
surtout le travail qui est fait sur
comment dire on a l'impression d'être au
louvre et de regarder des toiles de
maître les unes après les autres et on
est ébahi ébloui survivre que j'ai d'une
vingtaine de voix et à chaque fois je le
regarde avec un plaisir sans mélange en
rond en sachant que je pourrais le
revoir encore indéfiniment tellement
c'est beau alors on termine toujours
cette émission en musique et vous vous
avez choisi celle l'art l'écoutent
ensemble
à son genre tiens à reconnaître
ça
c'est pas moi
concerto pour piano numéro 2 en fa
majeur chostakovitch oui oui j'aime
beaucoup ce symbolique mais j'ai passé
non mais c'est pas celui là c'est pas
grave
vous lire autre chose nommée y allons
donc été magnifique l'andante qui était
qui c'est un point qui vous prend là
c'est un petit peu léger et ce
stakhanoviste intéressant parce que
c'était un musicien
officielle de l'époque stalinienne et on
voit qu'ils n'en pense pas moins et il
le dit à travers sa musique c'est à dire
que il ya à la fois ces musiques qui dit
la terreur la peur l'angoissé qui
tombent dessus et puis un temps il ya
toujours la ville la ville a d'ailleurs
vous avez la vie voilà il ya quelque
chose qui vit qui bouge et ses essais ça
en permanence donc je pense qu'il ne
pensait pas moins alors vous vous êtes
très amateur de musique classique on
peut vous écoutez d'ailleurs sur ce raid
de caciques et d'ailleurs votre prénom
france n'est pas le fruit totalement due
au hasard annoncé bon père qui était
complètement à foot schubert donc ils
écoutaient des oeuvres de schubert toute
sa vie incroyable je mets vins bon
c'était pire écouté et réécouté et quand
je suis né c'est vrai que l'on
m'appelait france qui m'appelait france
à cause de schubert et ma mère m'a
appelé olivier parce que je parlais mais
le prénom d'olivier pas de raison
particulière merci me prendre
aujourd'hui c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à chez françoise qui nous
a fuis zine et ses bons petits plats
comme semaine merci on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de politique à table sur lcp
[Musique]